my name is Lloyd and I am currently
their CEO here at Energon
so we started personal branding program
because we weren't getting anywhere near
enough engagement on LinkedIn and it was
really struggling to get our guys to
it's a post content on LinkedIn so we
need to do something about it we knew
him from from before and great guy so
decided to engage him and never look
back
since starting that the program with
Hisham we've actually achieved quite a
lot so when we when we started the
program we was reaching around 50,000
people on LinkedIn and over the last
that was a month so over the last six
weeks we've reached about half a million
which shows we've dramatically increased
our number of people that we've reached
so I think that in itself will make it
worth starting at the branding program
for sure but not only that we've had a
lot of people from the industry come
back to us and say that they now seen
our brand and recognized our brand on on
the internet which can only do wonders
for our brand going forwards
I think for me the main reason why I'd
recommend the personal branding program
is that the first discovery session
really got our people engaged with with
personal branding and getting content
out there we did a sort of a persona
session with Hisham that was amazing and
it really made our guys think about the
actual person they're trying to target
whether that be clients or candidates
which meant that they can't some really
really good ideas for content and then
that content gets engagement and then
you act on the back of that engagement
which hopefully is going to really drive
out our ROI going forward so for me I
think that the discovery session in the
beginning is probably one of the main
points the second point is the fact that
Hisham is on these guys so he shouldn't
come in and did the discovery session
and then constantly throughout the six
weeks program he's on top of them making
sure that we're getting the most out of
the investment that we've put into it so
Hisham in the personal branding program
which is really really driven some some
activity so first it would be the the
fact that he comes in and does a great
discovery session building personas and
second that he's actually on a guy's I
don't have a huge amount of time to do
it right now so Hisham has been that
added support I really needed